foreign
[Music]
the drills that'll have the most impact
in helping you move forward in your POI
Journey especially if you're a beginner
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
today I want to share with you the five
drills that I think are most important
for beginners to take on in order to
acquire the skills that they're going to
need to get ahead before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
beckonen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
there are so many things to learn out
there in the POI world how do you know
what to prioritize how do you know what
to practice how do you know what you
should be working on I've been teaching
point out for a decade and a half and in
that time I've noticed certain patterns
in terms of what people learn and what
people need as they're working through
their POI journey and I want to share
some of what I've learned with you and
specifically I want to give you the five
most effective drills that I have given
to beginners over the course of my
career the stuff that I have really seen
make them shine and set them up for
doing amazing things down the road and
we're going to start this off with a POI
technique that I like to call a Tic Tac
that is moving the POI back and forth
across your body a lot of us kind of
instinctually have a feel for this but I
like drilling it in a more systematic
fashion cool so I'm going to go ahead
and have you do 10 reps switching the
POI back and forth across your body in
six different positions the first one is
going to be right here moving your POI
back and forth across your body from
left to right and then back again think
that you get in one rep every time the
POI crosses and then crosses back so we
do one
two
three you want to do a total of 10 reps
with your hands sitting right in front
of you like this now you're going to go
ahead and extend your hand as far out
away from you in front of your body as
you possibly can and do another 10 reps
now you're going to go ahead and bend
your elbow so that the POI planes are
pointed up towards the ceiling now and
again get in 10 reps like this now our
next move is that we're going to switch
this from what we call Wheel plane over
into wall plane notice the difference
here in this position it looks like the
POI is moving back and forth and what's
essentially straight lines and in this
position it looks like the POI is moving
through circles so to get a feel for
this it might actually be helpful to
plant your feet and then turn your upper
body in the direction of the hand
holding the POI in this case to my right
I turn my entire body over to Stage
right and begin switching the POI back
and forth across my body you'll note if
my upper body were facing towards the
camera it would look exactly like the
last part of this drill but since I've
moved my upper body over towards stage
right as far as the camera is concerned
it looks like the POI is moving around
in circles on the side of me now I'm
going to go ahead and turn my head back
towards the camera while leaving the POI
going back and forth in front of and
behind my body it's literally the exact
same thing as this I'm just pointing my
head in a different direction again from
here we're going to have the hand just
hang out towards the side of us and then
extend as far out away from our bodies
it possibly can
and then bend the elbow to get these
planes moving up around your head and
neck you want to do 10 reps in each spot
so again that is 10 reps with the hand
out in front of us in wheel plane extend
it as far as it can in wheel plane and
with the elbow bent in wheel plane we
also want to get in 10 reps with the arm
next to us in wall plane the arm
extended completely as far out as it can
go in wall plane and the elbow bent in
wall plane this is going to help us get
down our plane bends in each of these
different planar orientations so we can
make choices about when the POI is in
ball playing and when it is in wheel
plane and that's real important next up
a basic drill that teaches all the
different modes of timing and direction
as well as how to transition between
them timing and direction if you're not
familiar is just how we talk about how
two objects can move around each other
in space there are four different modes
for timing and direction that we
recognize and this drill takes us
through all four of them so let's start
off by reviewing all four modes the
first mode is just together Time same
direction some people call this Earth
and basically it involves just moving
our hands around in a big circle in
front of us we want to keep our hands
parallel and even the entire way through
there's also together opposite which is
also sometimes called air now this
involves the hands coming together at
the top and bottom and splitting apart
on the sides and Crossing through the
middle so think they go down together
out apart up together and then split
apart as they go through
next up we have split Time same
direction which is going to involve
turning your body to one side basically
I'm going to turn towards stage right
here and I'm going to go ahead and make
like my arms are doing the crawl stroke
I want my hands to always be pointing
away from each other up and down side to
side up and down side to side I'm going
to need to turn my upper body back and
forth to open up my shoulders to either
side in order to make this work
please note I am in each of these
different timing and Direction modes
making sure that the camera slash
audience can see as big a profile of the
circles that I'm creating as possible
our final timing and Direction mode is
split time opposites which looks like
this it is just like doing double Dutch
jump roping and this is also called Fire
by some people
now the way you can practice this is
think that you're going to clap your
hands together and snap them with one up
and one down clap them together snap
them with one hand up and one down Clap
Snap Clap Snap to get a feel for
bringing our hands together and
separating them top and bottom cool so
the drill is to work your way between
all of them because each timing and
Direction mode shares two positions with
other timing and Direction modes let me
show you what I mean we begin with
together same and as we're going around
here I want you to stop when your hands
reach the bottom from here they'll
separate out and switch into together
opposite
from here you're going to stop your
hands when they're out to the sides turn
your upper body towards the side of the
stage and start moving your hands in
Split Time same direction
from here we're going to wait for this
moment when the left hand is up and the
right hand is down and they're going to
come together over to the right separate
come together over to the left separate
we're now in Split time opposites when
they come together over to the right we
can switch back into together same so
all together we want to do say four reps
and together same one
4 switch into together opposites one
two
three
four with our arms straight out to the
sides we switch into split Time same
direction One
two
three
four and then switch into split time
opposites one
two
three
four
and we start the whole thing over again
together same
together opposites
split Time same direction
and split time opposites this is going
to take a little bit of practice before
it starts to feel comfortable but once
you've got that in your body you will be
able to make these transitions with any
POI tricks as well so as cool as that is
our hands get to cheat because they
don't have to worry about gravity and
this next drill I'm going to show you
how you can get your POI on board to be
able to change timing in Direction two
using stalls alright so this drill is
going to require that you know how to do
several different things number one be
able to perform a butterfly in wall
plane in front of you it's also going to
require that with each hand you know how
to do a down stall and a bottom stall a
bottom stall is really just flinging the
POI out and being able to pull it back
in going the other direction so if you
have all these tricks under your belts
awesome if not I'll go ahead and include
links to tutorials for all of them down
in the description all right so here's
what this drill is going to look like
we're going to start off with our POI
spinning in together opposites or
butterfly and basically I'm going to
take the right hand pull way and I'm
going to start off by having it kind of
flung out to the side here and I'm going
to drag it back down and around so that
it switches Direction now both of the
POI are spinning clockwise in wall plane
in front of me now I'm going to stall
the right hand POI down and I'm going to
let the left hand POI keep on spinning
this takes a little bit of work because
we're basically getting our two hands to
do two different things but this is part
of the practice and one of the things
that you'll get out of this of course is
Independence between the two hands which
is really clutch
so now I'm going to bring back the right
hand bringing the POI up and over it and
we're going to return to a butterfly
now again that section was the right
hand POI pitches out comes back both POI
are spinning clockwise and wall plane
and the right hand POI stalls down comes
back in butterfly
we're going to do the same thing on the
left side now the left hand POI is going
to stall out
come back down and around we wind up
with both of the POI spinning
counterclockwise relative to us in front
of us in wall plane
then it's going to stall down the right
hand point is going to keep on spinning
and it's going to come back in
so that they are spinning in butterfly
again the left hand pitches out comes
back counterclockwise
pitches down
comes back in as a butterfly so we're
going to go right hand stalls
right hand stalls
left hand stalls
left hand stalls the whole pattern being
butterfly
clockwise butterfly
counterclockwise
butterfly and we think right
right
left
not only will this give you so much
control over your timing and Direction
changes but it'll also really drill in
those stalls as well as give you a lot
of control over your abilities to do
different things with different hands
next up we're going to play around with
three different ways that our hand and
POI can move in tandem with each other
so the foundation here is that our hand
is just going to move around in a big
circle and we've got a bunch of options
for what the POI can be doing as our
hand is performing this the first option
is that the POI just does what we call a
pendulum that is we never put enough
energy into the POI to let it go over
the hand it's always hanging below it so
it kind of goes across us in a straight
line on top and down and around
underneath the hand on bottom
next we work our way up to what we would
call an extension that is the POI itself
becomes an extension of our hand and
we're putting enough energy into it that
it just stands out as a straight line
going from our shoulder
and then we go ahead and turn this into
a flower namely an inspin flower I'm
going to add extra spins to the POI as
my hand moves around a circle I'm going
to add two petals so I'm spinning the
POI head around the hand on top and on
bottom
so all told I'm going pendulum
for eight reps
extension for eight reps and inspin
flower for eight reps and then I work my
way back down to an extension
and then a pendulum what this is
designed to teach you is how much energy
you have to put into the POI in order to
achieve the different POI patterns and
shapes that you're looking to this is
really helpful for developing a lot of
nuance in how you move the POI and of
course be able to transition between a
variety of different moves all right so
before I share with you my final pick
for the POI drill for beginners that I
think is most important I have a favor
to ask if you come this far I'm going to
guess that it means that you are
interested in learning POI and guess
what I create lots of videos on that
topic so if you wouldn't mind going
ahead and leaving a like for this video
and subscribing to the channel you'll be
able to know the next time I upload a
video and even better than that you'll
help my channel grow alright and now my
last pick for the most important drills
that I give to beginners is performing
real turns
now this might seem kind of
underwhelming but this actually teaches
something really really important and in
fact this was a trick that I learned
back in the day that caused me so much
consternation because I had a tough time
with the central concept buried within
it all right so let me show you
something kind of wild here right now I
have the two POI spinning forwards at
either side of my body and what I'm
going to go ahead and do is I'm going to
go ahead and bring the right POI over so
they're both on the same side of my body
and then cross the left point over to
the other side of my body
now relative to me it looks like the POI
are spinning reverse I have turned from
forwards to reverse now I'm going to
bring them back both to the same side of
my body I'm going to let them both go up
towards the ceiling and when they come
back down they'll be split once again to
either side of my body so there's a
couple interesting things that happen
here the first is that relative to me it
looks like the POI have changed
Direction have you noticed that in the
course of that also each of them have
had to switch which side of my body
they're on my right hand moves over to
what feels like my left side and my left
hand moves all the way over to the left
when both of those actions have happened
it looks to me as though the POI had
changed Direction but before that
I'm in a space where they either look
like they're both going forwards both
clockwise both reverse and then going
back
they're back to clockwise the lesson
buried inside of this is something
called plane facing that is whenever I
turn with the POI I have to bear in mind
they're going to switch which side of my
body they're on when that happens from
my perspective the direction the POI are
spinning in changes right here they
appear to be spinning clockwise relative
to me and when I'm on the same side of
them that the camera is they appear to
both be spinning counterclockwise
so this is a good thing to keep in mind
when you're moving around with POI at
all and just drilling these reels is a
great way to start to build this
information into your brain we humans
naturally want the objects that we use
to move along with us so as far as we're
concerned the POI should always be
moving forwards right and we always find
it so confusing when the POI doesn't
seem to move the way we expect it to
when if we learn how to move in tandem
with the object and let the object move
the way that it wants to according to
its own momentum and inertia all of a
sudden our capacity to move with it gets
much much smoother and to my eyes looks
a lot cooler so all told the drill here
is just to work on doing 10 real turns
across one side of your body and then
doing 10 real turns across the other
side of your body
and then being able to do a 360 degree
turn
in One Direction
say 10 reps
and then doing a 360 degree turn the
other direction for 10 reps
just like that Wicked so those are my
picks for my top five favorite drills to
give to beginners what did you think of
these drills were any of these things
useful to you also if you dug these
drills and you'd like more of them I
produce a weekly drill for my patreon
supporters if you sign up at the flow
Circle level over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi you will get a new drill
just like any of the five that I just
demonstrated delivered straight to your
inbox every single week to help you
practice and get ahead in your POI
spinning so give that a look did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like share comment and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
thank you
this video would not have been possible
without the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you all so very much for your
support for my channel my work and my
mission and if you'd like to check out
more beginner POI lessons I will go
ahead and include a link to some videos
that I've done down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also if you're
watching on YouTube this top video right
here is something the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like because it
has been popular with other viewers of
my channel
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon
peace